ايش الشاش وين الشاش بصور هي شاش هي شاشه
بصور هي
شاشه انا الدكتور هانف
سيسو موجودين في بيتنا صفو يا عمو هذه
بنتي تتصوروا انا بعملها بت لرجلها في
الدار ايش اليهود بدهم مننا ايش الظلم
اللي واقع علينا احنا محصلين الا 15 يوم
بنتي بقطع لها رجلها من دون بنش وين
الرحمه وين الانسانيه ايش الزلم ايش الذنب
اللي احنا عملناه طاوله المطبخ انا بعمل
على طاوله المطبخ من دون بنج بقطع رجل بنت
عمرها 16 17 سنه من دون بنج وين الرحه
ارحمنا يا رب ارحمنا يا رب هذا ظلم كبير
واقع علينا وين الامه العربيه
الاسلاميه قول يا رب يا قل يا
رب ربنا نزل عليها الصبر اقسم بالله
العظيم الصبر بس من عند ربك اما احنا ما
بدنا من حد شي حسبي الله ونعم
الوكيل البات
جنبينا يلا انا مش قادر اوصلها على
المستشفى انا قاعد في البيت مش قادر اصلا
مستشفى الشفا وانا في شارع
اللبابيدي بيني وبين مستشفى الشيفا خمس
دقاق
j